la viande ce n'est pas juste du boeuf du
porc ou de la volaille c'est aussi du
gibier d'élevage canard serre et mailhac
sangliers wapiti lapin ou encore bison
pour ne nommer que ceux là watson ronge
c'est très juteux
moi c'est une viande très tendre il ya
juste cinq petites marinade attend que
j'ai jamais cuisiné sers de ma vie
j'arrive à l'épicerie je commencerai par
quoi il y en a fondu facile un but de la
soirée c'est beau c'est bon ça peut être
très belle alternative à la consommation
de baisse embêtant l'épicerie à
découvert ou redécouvert tout c'est bien
on voit ici un canard traditionnelle qui
n'a pas été gavés donc un canard pékin
qu'on peut dire et puis si un canard qui
a été gavé
un nullard
le canard est le plus populaire en 2019
il s'en est vendu 600 tonnes au québec
en comparaison cette année là il s'est
vendu 53 mille tonnes de poulets
en cette période d'inflation parmi
toutes les augmentations du prix des
aliments c'est celle de la viande de
boeuf qui fait le plus mal
c'est sûr que c'est un petit coup de
plus pour nous pousser vers tout ce qui
est végétarien diminuer la consommation
de viande et le prix de la viande de
gibier est à la hausse lui aussi
vous est ce que l'inflation eu un impact
aussi important sur votre créneau c'est
en cours à ce mauvais l'homme est en
train de lever jeu qu'elle n'avait pas
que ça va avoir les producteurs nous en
parle le prix des grains et augmente
donc sont obligés d'augmenter
d'avoir des meilleurs prix pour le pour
le produit après ça nous de retourner ce
héros cela au détail la restauration
gibier cannes à bec est un important
distributeur de viande de gibier
d'élevage au canada depuis 35 ans
aujourd'hui on off le wapiti sang rouge
sangliers dont pintade
la faisant de liège pif d'amin le canard
le canard gros canons maigre dont
s'approvisionne principalement au québec
parfois on va s'approvisionner au sinon
l'ouest canadien et bien sûr la pandémie
n'a pas épargné le secteur de la chaîne
alimentaire ça a été une période
difficile en fait comme pour les
restaurateurs qui sont la moitié de
notre clientèle
les producteurs lyon doit être vraiment
très résilient pour passer à travers
pendant la pandémie les ventes au détail
ont augmenté
il y en a beaucoup qui sont retournés
vers la vente directe au consommateur à
la ferme aussi
spécialisée dans l'élevage de bison et
de wapiti la terre des bisons est une
entreprise agrotouristique qui fait de
la vente directe les gens ils veulent
vraiment savoir d'où viennent leurs
nourritures nous au fil des années des
28 années de production on a fait les
portes ouvertes sur les fermes de l'upm
puis les gens ici qui nous posaient des
questions très peace fait comment vous
produisez qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que fait pour l'environnement
puis les questions sont de plus en plus
pointues concernant tout ce qui est à
gros environnement meilleur 20 ans
s'était pas autant de questions qu'on se
faisait poser c'est plutôt bien ça se
mange du bison parce quand on a parti
les gens savaient même pas qu'on puisse
s'alimenter avec du bison
le côté environnement y venu avec le
temps parce que les gens sont plus
informés
puis ils ont besoin de se faire rassurer
sur le ce qu'ils mangent
au cours des dix dernières années
l'abattage de gibier au canada a baissé
d'environ 25 pour ça pour la viande de
bison par exemple cela représente
aujourd'hui des ventes d'environ trente
et une tonne au québec ce qui est deux
mille fois moins que le boeuf avec plus
de soixante mille tonnes
dans le nouveau guide alimentaire
canadien qui spécifie favoriser des
bancaires entre autres les viandes de
gibier spéciquement sont cités dans le
guide alimentaire canadien on recommande
ces viandes pour leur richesse en faire
et leur faible teneur en gras
malgré qu'elle soit moins consommer
elles sont à considérer comme une
alternative intéressante
puis on sait qu'on a une provenance
locale puis on a ou soeurs respect le
bien-être animal c'est des élevages et
qui sont faites en liberté il n'ya pas
d'hormone de croissance
pas de médication les parts dans
lesquelles ces lessard aux exemples sont
élevés c'est magnifique
les détaillants collabore à la promotion
de la viande de gibier au ils sont à
l'écouté des nouveaux aux tripes ils
sont là aussi pour voir qu'est ce que
les consommateurs recherchent puis on
leur fait des propositions on va mettre
des choses de la mer dans les
circulaires on va lui mettre la dame
magasins et pour les faire découvrir il
ya beaucoup de laboratoires le canard
lgi bill plus populaires si son marché a
souffert de la pandémie comme tous les
autres c'était sans compter sur une
autre tuile
aujourd'hui l'on se retrouve avec la
guitare hier avec des entreprises l'eau
qui on est gros défi à relever je vous
dirais avec ce qui se passe dans le
canal on peut s'attendre à des pénuries
un petit peu à la fin de l'année les
gens peut-être devrait essayer d'autres
d'autres de la regza d'autres protéines
peut-être peut-être l'accueil peut-être
du lapin de la pintade pour peut-être
essayer le wapiti qui est moins connu un
petit peu au québec les gens connaissent
la sarre rougemont petit peu moins le
wapiti quand les gens l'essai défaut
vont nous dire waouh c'est ma préférée
finalement les viandes de gibier sont
environ 10% plus cher que les viandes
traditionnels je pense que ça va rester
des produits de niche mais je pense
qu'ils sont pas encore assez apprécié à
leur juste valeur parce qu'on a fait et
les gens peut-être les connaissent
encore où est ce que la tendance de pour
manger moins de viande un impact votre
avis sur votre marché ben je pense que
oui mais les gens veulent manger de la
bonne viande c'est là que nous je crois
que le bison on va rentrer là dedans
parce que c'est un élevage qui est santé
qui donne une viande de qualité
je pense à vaut la peine d fois de faire
un petit détour puis d'aller
s'approvisionner directement chez le
producteur